[Musique]
il
david c'est un plaisir de vous avoir
avec nous dans cette émission
comme vous le savez elles s'appellent
sofico visionnarts is et vous êtes un
vrai visionnaire dans votre domaine
beaucoup de questions nous ont été
envoyées je ne suis pas une
professionnelle
je vais vous poser des questions assez
simple ce qui intéresse la plupart des
gens je suis près d'accord très bien
j'ai les dernières statistiques de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
selon eux le nombre de cas de cancer et
de décès liés au cancer augmente et je
me dis que nous avons ton de nouvelles
technologiques temps de recherches ont
été faites perdons-nous toujours la
bataille
cela ne fait aucun doute nous sommes en
train de perdre la bataille pour deux
raisons principales la première est que
nous continuons de fumée de tabac reste
la principale cause de décès liés au
cancer dans le monde et nous fumons les
femmes fument plus que jamais si
certains taux baissent ils augmentent
dans de nombreuses régions du monde
la deuxième raison est que tous les
nouveaux traitements que nous avons qui
sont vraiment incroyables nous pouvons
désactiver les interrupteurs de cancer
nous pouvons faire en sorte que notre
propre système immunitaire attaque le
cancer ne font jamais que retarder les
choses on ne guérit pas on gagne du
temps et du temps de qualité
je suis donc optimiste quant au fait que
nous pouvons contrôler mais nous ne
serons pas en mesure de guérir les gens
continueront de mourir de cette horrible
maladie
nous avons du chemin à faire vous voulez
dire que le cancer est incurable un bon
on peut pas le soigner mais on peut le
contrôler si je vous dis que vous avez
diabète
il n'allait pas tout de suite vous jeter
d'un pont vous direz je vais gérer ça
dans le cas du cancer ce sera la même
chose le cancer devrait être un verbe et
non un nom tout cancéreux c'est quelque
chose que produit le corps ce n'est pas
quelque chose que le corps contracte
donc mon travail est de vous faire
passer d'un état vous avez un cancer à
un état vous êtes en bonne santé
c'est tout à fait différent de
l'ancienne méthode qui consistait à
cibler la cellule et à la détruire
je veux changer votre est terminée c'est
très intéressant on cette idée de
considérer le terme cancer comme un
verbe pourquoi le corps commence-t-il à
se comporter comme ça c'est une question
à un million ou à un milliard de dollars
la réponse est que nous n'en savons rien
et nous savons par exemple ce qui est
une inflammation
c'est un état qui est associée au cancer
si vous avez une inflammation poumon
causés par le tabagisme si vous avez une
inflammation n'importe qui dans le corps
cela augmente considérablement le risque
de cancer est donc l'une des méthodes de
prévention que nous avons et de bleu
leur flamme à une pilule qui si on la
prend tous les jours résumons pas la
fréquence mais le taux de mortalité du
cancer de 30%
elle s'appelle baby aspirine ainsi une
aspirine par jour réduit le risque
d'inflammation et diminue
considérablement le taux de mortalité du
coup il y at il des effets secondaires
prendre une aspirine par jour pourrait
être mauvais pour votre chose le seul
effet que l'aspirine peut avoir c'est
une irritation de l'estomac une légère
prolongation de saignements pour la
majorité des gens ce n'est pas un
problème mais il faut en discuter avec
votre médecin
normalement c'est tout à fait hors de
danger si aux états unis tout le monde
prenaient de l'aspirine un dc 10 ans
neuf cent mille personnes seraient
toujours en vie et nous économiserions
600 milliards de dollars de dépenses de
santé le problème est que nous sommes
assez peu intéressés par la prévention
si je vous dit sophie fait ça
aujourd'hui cela vous sera utile dans 10
ou 20 ans vous allez levez les yeux au
ciel
non je le ferai que dois-je faire
prendre et spirit tous les jours de
l'aspirine une statines des médicaments
comme le lipitor mais il ya aussi
beaucoup de questions comportementales
moi je ne fume pas mais le tabagisme
passif il y a toujours des gens autour
de moi qui fume ça ne fait aucun doute
c'est à dire que nous vivons dans une
ville en russie où les gens fument
encore dès qu'on le veuille ou non on
fait face au tabagisme passif
il ya la pollution atmosphérique ici
vous savez nous faisons donc tous face
aux risques de cancer le cancer est
toujours le dessus en numéro 1 ou 2 quel
que soit le pays où l'on street j'ai
entendu parler d'une idée très
intéressante selon laquelle le cancer
serait une sorte de créature qui se bat
pour sa survie
qu'en pensez vous c'est une chose
incroyable si on y réfléchit
cette créature essaie de prendre tous
venus trimant de paradoxe est qu à la
fin si elle vous tuer elmer également le
cancer nous permet d'en apprendre
beaucoup sur l'évolution c'est à partir
de là qu'il faut commencer la réflexion
il y à de nouveaux moyens créatifs qui
permet d'en tirer des avantages
vous savez on peut bloquer l'apport
sanguin pour une façon de traiter le
cancer désormais ne ciblons pas le
cancer nous sommes en train de le
changer
pour le cas du cancer du sein dans les
plus grands progrès réalisés dans son
traitement n'est pas un médicament qui
ciblent le cancer
c'est un médicament qui change la hausse
il a été conçu contre l'ostéoporose car
le cancer du sein va vers les eaux si on
change le sol là
ne pousse pas changé le sol l'empêchent
de pousser nous prescrivons donc un
médicament contre l'ostéoporose
nous prolongeons considérablement la vie
malgré un cancer du sein c'est une
incroyable découverte
si je comprends bien logiquement les
cellules cancéreuses sont celles qui ne
meurent pas ce qui explique pourquoi les
gens eux meurent là c'est correct mais
une personne en bonne santé il finit par
mourir parce que ces cellules meurent en
vieillissant donc en étudiant le cancer
pourrions nous trouver la clé de
l'immortalité
c'est bien vrai je veux dire que c'est
ce que nous recherchons et ce sur quoi
nous en apprenons tous les jours un peu
plus
il ya un vieil adage qui veut la paix
prépare la guerre à mener la guerre
contre le cancer mme en a énormément
appris sur d'autres maladies sur le
corps humain et la longévité
c'est quelque chose j'ai fait une
découverte surprenante si je me
promenais à cet instant dans les rues de
moscou et prenaient des échantillons de
sang d'une centaine de personnes je
découvrirai que huit d'entre elles ont
les marqueurs de la leucémie dans le
sens mais n'ont pas de leçon lorsque
pour qu'il cède le cmes ils ont besoin
de changement adn et d'un environnement
réceptif à l'avenir l'une des grandes
orientations médical sera de cibler
l'environnement de changer la personne
de manière à ce que je cancer ne puisse
pas avoir mais le cancer a toujours
existé où on ne sait pas s'il s'agit là
de quelque chose qui était paru durant
le siècle précédent où il y a deux ou
trois siècles
est ce la pollution tout le monde dit
tout ça c'est à cause de la pollution à
cause des produits génétiquement
modifiés c'est de là que vient le cancer
et puis il ya le tabagisme et d'autres
raisons
si vous regardez les momies égyptiennes
la plupart d'entre elles sont mortes
d'un cancer le cancer a donc toujours
été là comment sait-on cela dit maxime
omis ont été préservés et nous pouvons
constater les cancers qu'ont développé
leur corps on voit qu'elle avait le
cancer du sein le cancer du poumon le
cancer de la prostate aussi nous avons
des cas qui ont eu lieu il ya trois
quatre mille ans nous étudions dans la
nature d'autres animaux et chez les
animaux qui vivent dans la nature
beaucoup d'entre eux aussi meurent du
cancer le cancer est bien là ce qui est
intéressant est que le cancer est apparu
pour nous faire partir avec l'évolution
nous avons eu nos enfants vers l'âge de
30-35 ans et le cancer nous fait partir
pour laisser plus de ressources à la
génération suivante le cancer fait donc
une partie de nous il devait arriver
vous comme moi vont un incroyable
système inflammatoires parce que
d'autres sont morts 2
l'a10 infectieuses nous avons
aujourd'hui des antibiotiques des
antiviraux et des vaccins pour pouvoir
apaiser les inflammations vivre beaucoup
plus longtemps et retarder le cancer de
manière significative
nous vivons dans un avenir proche avec
un concert comme vous avez dit au début
comme des gens vivent avec le diabète ou
le vih
j'avais 20 ans si quelqu'un avait le vih
ils étaient sûrs d'en mourir désormais
des gens vivent avec ce virus et mène
une vie normale sont actifs ils
travaillent ils ont des familles
pourront nous faire ça avec un cancer
vivre une longue vie il ya quatre ans le
président jimmy carter a annoncé qu'il
avait un mélanome un cancer de la peau
qui a métastasé jusqu'au cerveau c'est
une condamnation à mort on lui a
prescrit un médicament pour bloquer le
signal de défense de son cancer
permettant à son propre système
immunitaire d'attaquer ce dernier est
aujourd'hui il est encore en train de
prêcher à l'église d'éduquer les enfants
de construire des maisons pour les
pauvres car son cancer est sous contrôle
je pense que c'est un objectif
réalisable vous savez ma vie a changé à
la fin des années 90 j'étais médecin à
sloan kettering et j'étais avec le
directeur de l'hôpital un grand médecin
j'étais son stagiaire dans la salle est
entré un jeune de 25 ans avec des
cellules cancéreuses au cerveau aux
poumons et au foie
le médecin lui a dit écoute tu as
quelques mois à vivre je veux que tu
passes ces quelques derniers mois auprès
de ta mère parce que ta mère est seul et
que la chimiothérapie ne fera que rendre
malade
ce jeune homme est reparti il a fait des
recherches c'était avant google il a
trouvé qu'un médecin avait fait une
expérience avec deux électrodes de
platine placé dans un gel pour envoyer
aux cellules cancéreuses comme de
l'électricité électricité n'avait pas
d'importance pour eux mais le platine
oui c'est comme dans ma bague de mariage
à l'absorber tuer certaines cellules
alors il a dit je veux du platine blu
est donc un geste et du platine par
intraveineuse un an et demi plus tard il
remportait le premier de ses sept tours
de france c'est l ensam strong donc vous
voyez lense étaient condamnés à morts et
les vivants aux rats pourquoi je ne sais
pas comment le platine fonctionne mais
il a changé son corps de manière à ce
que le cancer ne veulent pas grandir
donc oui je pense que nous pouvons vie
longtemps et en bonne santé avec le
cancer ne pas en mourir tout de suite
il est encore temps de méthode que nous
ne connaissons pas on vous avait parlé
du platine qui l'aurait cru
c'est un système complexe vous savez si
quelqu'un vous dit je peux prédire la
météo je sais exactement ce qui va se
passer
vous savez qu'il est fou c'est la même
chose en médecine les grands
modélisateurs climatique examine la
forme du nuage et à partir de ça ils
peuvent déduire ce qui va se passer ne
vont pas là haut pour mesurer 50000
variable je pense que les médecins
seront plus comme des modélisateurs du
climat à l'avenir que des biologistes
ils vont suivre ces tendances vous savez
quand vous étiez enfant votre mère
faisait comme ça elle savait que vous
étiez malade elle ne vous prélevez pas
de sens examinée par aux lymphocytes et
votre taux de cytokines
elle suivait une tendance donc nous
devons avoir plus de méthodes comme ça
je pense que dans un sens c'est en
considérant cela comme un système qu'on
va changer les choses
vous avez parlé du président carter et
de son système immunitaire
je ne sais pas si c'est un mythe ou non
mais divers médecins et patients m'ont
dit qu'il était possible de guérir et de
tuer le cancer lui-même mais avec tous
les différents traitements ont réduit à
quasiment zéro
le système immunitaire du patient afin
d'essayer réellement ce traitement pour
que l'organisme de la personne ne
résiste pas aux traitements qu'elle
reçoit ensuite le cancer meurt mais le
système immunitaire est détruit au point
que le patient ne peut survivre et meurt
c'est bien ça non ça vous savez la
chimiothérapie est apparue parce qu'on
utilisait lors de la première guerre
mondiale de la zot pour faire les bombes
et les gens qu'ils manipulaient ces
bombes voyaient leur nombre de globules
blancs passé à 0 alors on s'est dit oh
mon dieu
utilisons ces mêmes produits chimiques
pour traiter la leucémie et voilà
c'était la première chimiothérapie ainsi
l'ancienne génération de chimiothérapie
celle des années 50 60 et 70 frappé le
cancer globalement et toutes cellules à
division rapide cellules cancéreuses et
toutes les cellules immunitaires et
nouvelles formes de thérapies sont
ciblés elle frappe
l'interrupteur dans le cancer elle ne
supprime pas le système immunitaire
nous sommes entrés dans une nouvelle ère
où nous pouvons réellement alimenter le
système
immunitaire comme dans le cas de jimmy
carter ou nous pouvons cibler les
interrupteurs ce qui fonctionne bien et
fait gagner de nombreuses années de vie
de qualité
je me demande aussi quelles sont les
conditions pour que quelqu'un est un
cancer c'est évidemment la pollution
n'est ce pas et quand les gens disent
que la pollution plastique ou la 5g sont
à l'origine de cancers que vous y croyez
il ya certainement des relations entre
certaines choses et le cancer certains
types de plastiques
si vous les utilisez pour boire au
quotidien peuvent perturber votre
système endocrinien et augmenter le
risque de certains cancers
mais si on prend en compte les
principales causes de cancer aujourd'hui
non ce n'est pas nécessairement notre
environnement
les gens disaient que les téléphones
portables causer des cancers il
causerait le cancer du cerveau parce que
lui parler au téléphone mais la
fréquence du cancer du cerveau n'a pas
du tout changé depuis 1970 si les
téléphones cellulaires et est à
l'origine du cancer du cerveau celui ci
aurait dû devenir plus fréquents or ce
n'est pas le cas donc si vous regardez
les tendances la seule tendance réelle
que nous constatons le seul changement
que nous constatons sur les deux
dernières décennies
c'est le cancer du côlon chez les jeunes
devient de plus en plus fréquents c'est
parce qu'il ya plus d'obésité
le cancer du côlon est associé à
l'obésité donc en général même si
l'environnement et contribuer le cancer
malheureusement apparaît tout simplement
il fait partie de nous notre travail est
donc de le prévenir ce que nous pouvons
faire en grande partie s'il est
identifiée tôt on peut le guérir à ce
moment c'est sur cela que devrait se
focaliser la communauté médicale
[Musique]
le concert des pentes ilha do on vient
géographiquement
je veux dire de la race ou de l'éthnie
je ne sais pas s'il est fou de poser des
questions comme ça mais j'ai lu quelque
part que par exemple les femmes
ashkénaze et teddy % plus sujettes à
développer un cancer du sein que
d'autres nationalités et origine
ethnique
ça va être intéressant qu'il y ait un
gène pour le cancer du sein qui
s'appelle le brc a il est très répandu
chez les femmes juive ashkénaze pour
elle le risque est donc plus élevé
néanmoins en général la plupart des
cancers ne sont pas génétique rare
google a acheté la base de données
ancestry.com et ils ont essayé de
trouver les gènes de la longévité
ils ont découvert que la longévité n'est
due qu'à 6% à la génétique il ya 94 %
comportement c'est à dire ce que vous
faites
même s'il y ait un lien entre les jeunes
et le cancer il est plutôt rare
la plupart des cancers apparaissent tout
simplement pas faire des choses pour le
prévenir on peut être actif toute la
journée on peut avoir petite masse
corporelle car ça marche on peut faire
des pratiques anti inflammatoire
préventive
tout cela marche et en général pour la
majorité des gens on ne peut pas dire
que l'environnement soit l'origine
donc si quelqu'un me dit il y a un
cancer du sein dans votre famille ou un
cancer tout court dans votre famille
donc vous devriez faire des examens
réguliers
je ne devrais pas les écouter s'il faut
les écouter vous savez tout d'abord le
comportement se définit par la famille
votre comportement est similaire à celui
de votre mère et de votre grand mère
ces facteurs de risque sont donc souvent
lié au comportement ensuite il ya
certainement une composante génétique
certaines familles ont un gène quand on
a une mutation brca1 comme angelina
jolie par exemple on a presque 90% de
chances d'avoir un cancer du sein dans
sa vie le cancer du sein est l'une des
maladies qui sont très fréquentes chez
les femmes une femme sur six sera ce
cancer idée très répandue
nous devons donc le prévenir peu importe
qui vous êtes peu importe quelle est
l'histoire de votre famille il faut
faire une mammographie faire un auto
examen ça marche ça permet d'identifier
tôt la maladie et la rend beaucoup plus
facile à traiter
pour l'instant sur le cas du président
carter un pote la médecine sur mesure
est-elle notre avenir
qu'en pensez vous je ne pense pas que
soit l'avenir je pense que c'est déjà le
cas je pense que nous
sommes nous pouvons aujourd'hui dans le
cas de chaque patient atteint d'un
cancer étudié les gènes sur le marché il
ya maintenant plus d'une douzaine de
médicaments à ciblage moléculaire qui
peuvent contrôler le cancer du poumon
une pilule par jour permet de faire en
sorte que le cancer s'endorment pouvons
débloquer le système immunitaire bloqué
ce signal de résistance du cancer pour
les cancers du rein de la pose du poumon
nous observons des résultats
spectaculaires chez des patients qui
était censé mourir et qui vivent en ce
moment avec la maladie nous sommes dans
une nouvelle ère nul guérissons pas
cette maladie les gens meurent encore il
ya beaucoup plus d'espoir et d'optimisme
que pouvez vous dire des vitamines sans
limite
il ya dix ans tout le monde disait vous
devez ingéré des oméga c'est bien votre
corps ça prévient l'apparition d'un
cancer
aujourd'hui on dit que ça n'aide
vraiment pas que ça ne fait rien on
disait que si notre système immunitaire
est affaibli
il fallait prendre des vitamines tous
les matins pour aller mieux
c'est vrai il n'y a aucun lien non ça
n'a aucun rapport
tout d'abord vous savez une vitamine est
quelque chose que le corps ne peut pas
synthétiser suffisamment c'est donc en
prendre une grande quantité ne procure
aucun avantage
en fait si un homme prendre la vitamine
e il augmente le risque d'avoir un
cancer de la prostate de 17%
les femmes qui prennent des
multivitamines ont un taux de cancer
plus élevé que les femmes qui ne font
pas pour se débarrasser des mauvaises
cellules endommagées votre corps produit
des radicaux libres
si vous prenez des antioxydants à haute
dose et ses vitamines bloquer vos
processus naturel et vous rendez le
cancer possible on attend toujours
l'étude positif qui montrerait que les
vitamines et compléments alimentaires
sont bénéfiques aux hommes et aux femmes
c'est incroyable un business à plusieurs
milliards de dollars mais aucun bénéfice
en terme de santé vous faire économiser
un peu d'argent
donc il n'y a aucun avantage à reprendre
qu'est-ce que je prends je prends de la
vitamine d parce qu'il ya peu de soleil
en russie faut-il que j'arrête les
femmes qui prennent de la vitamine d ont
un taux plus élevé de fractures osseuses
que les femmes qui n'en prennent pas
vous savez que le corps humain un moyen
pour éviter de recevoir trop de vitamine
d ça s'appelle le bronzage la raison
pour laquelle nous proposons et ce
blocage de la vitamine b
lorsque vous prenez de la vitamine d
dans une pilule vous réguler le capteur
est perturbé à la signalisation n'est
pas sujette aux rachitisme qui est un
manque clinique de vitamine d il n'a pas
été observé depuis longtemps dans ce
pays il n'y a donc aucun doute que les
vitamines supplémentaires et les
compléments ne procure aucun avantage à
l'individu moyen
qu'en est il des nouvelles technologies
par exemple les nano robots
ça me surprend ces petites créatures
qu'on laisse entrer dans son sens et qui
nettoie en quelque sorte l'organisme de
n'importe quel virus yettaw
cela peut-il aider dans le cas du cancer
les technologies ont un grand potentiel
il y a deux ans le 1er octobre je suis
sûr que vous vous en souvenez quelque
chose de passionnant avait eu lieu
c'est le jour on a annoncé qu'elle était
la molécule de l'année c'est un peu
comme aux oscars cette année là c'était
série s p r c'est une enzyme qui peut
changer une lettre dans les 3 milliards
de lettres du code adn
nous avons donc la capacité d'éditer des
choses de l'utiliser avec un nanorobot
qui peut réellement aller dans des
endroits et changer les choses c'est un
potentiel fou vous avez un scientifique
en chine à modifier des embryons et
trois enfants sont nés grâce à cette
technologie est malheureusement il ne
l'a pas fait correctement il n'a pas
respecté l'éthique et ses enfants vont
avoir des problèmes à mesure qu'ils
vieillissent avec la science adéquate en
bonne gouvernance et une éthique
approprié je pense que le potentiel est
là pour qu'on puisse vraiment avoir une
énorme influence sur la santé humaine je
pourrais changer vos propres cellules
immunitaires pour attaquer le cancer est
une attaque on que le cancer cela
doit-il être faits au stade embryonnaire
tu changes et les gènes alors que s pour
le cancer non pouvons prélever vos
cellules immunitaires et agir sur elle
il existe une technologie approuvé par
l'agencé américaine des produits
alimentaires et médicamenteux
elle est approuvée aux états unis il ya
un enfant atteint de leucémie sur qui
rien n'a marché ils prélèvent ces
globules blancs les expédier au new
jersey où se trouve le labo et introduit
un gène qui permet à ces globules blancs
de cibler la leucémie de l'enfant
85% des enfants qui ont littéralement
deux à trois semaines à vivre entre en
rémission thérapie remarquable qui
s'appelle à crtc thérapie guéret les
enfants atteints de leucémie qui
auraient pu mourir c'est donc une
nouvelle ère et c'est une aire très
prometteuse néanmoins il est beaucoup
plus facile de prévenir une maladie que
de la traiter
me concentre donc toujours sur la
prévention si nous avons de meilleurs
résultats dans ce sens ainsi plus vous
prévenez longtemps et mieux ces
technologies traiterons tous du cancer à
la maladie d'alzheimer en passant par
les maladies garde encore une question
sur l'édition génétique
si vous détectez par exemple une cellule
cancéreuse chez un embryon et que vous
l'enlevez que vous le remplacer par une
cellule saine et cela signifie t'il
qu'une fois la pratique répandue
nous aurons à l'avenir une population en
bonne santé sans cancer
alors on peut être né avec un gène
défectueux qui peut conduire au cancer
mais cela peut tout simplement arrivés
au cours de la vie qu'on soit exposé à
la lumière du soleil qui peut causer le
cancer de la peau ou le tabagisme ou que
cela arrive tout simplement les cancers
se produiront toujours mais nous pouvons
nous débarrasser de la drépanocytose de
la maladie de sachs d'erreur adn guinée
qui peuvent conduire à un cancer comme
le brc à eugène d'angelina jolie qui
nous pouvons éliminer ça vous savez il
ya cette nouvelle méthode consistant à
affamer son corps ou 100 d'une certaine
manière vos cellules se débarrasser de
toutes les toxines et choses inutiles
vous vous retrouvez en bonne santé il y
avait l'air jeune est-ce quelque chose
qui pourrait aussi aider à lutter si
c'est le bon mot contre le cancer
peut-on aussi attaquer les cellules
cancéreuses qui sont dans notre corps
pour empêcher le cancer d'apparaître
c'est sûrement le rêve de tout un chacun
de pouvoir dire à son corps faisons un
redémarrage rapide
vous savez votre ordinateur à un bug ou
le redémarrer et tout va à merveille
nous rêvons pouvoir faire cela on
croyait que l'autophagie revenait au
même certaines personnes en parler mais
cela n'a vraiment pas marcher dans ce
sens comme je le dis le cancer est en
nous il fait partie de nous il n'existe
pas malheureusement je ne connais aucun
élément me prouvant que cette méthode
pourrait être utilisée pour lutter
contre la maladie aujourd'hui retrouvé
beaucoup de choses sur internet
une fois qu'on fait des essais cliniques
on voit que ça ne marche pas cela étant
dit limiter son alimentation présente
des avantages
je crois que les gens ont besoin de
période de jeûne faut éviter de
grignoter entre le dîner le petit
déjeuner le petit déjeuner le déjeuner
pendant cette période ne mangeait pas et
l'insuline le cortisol les hormones du
stress besson lorsque votre corps ne
sais pas ce qui doit arriver
ces hormones reste au même niveau et
c'est stressant manger une simple pomme
entre le déjeuner et le dîner change
réellement votre métabolisme pour deux à
trois jours on prend du poids on ne
pense pas à ça et on ne fait pas assez
d'exercice
nous avons été conçu pour avoir des
périodes sans nourriture entre les repas
nous devons revenir à cela il y a
maintenant une nouvelle tendance
tout le monde fait ça du moins ici on
mange pas pendant 16 heures on respecte
ans d'intervalle par exemple vous avez
mangé pour la dernière fois à 20h puis
vous ne mangez pas jusqu'à 12h 14h le
lendemain normalement les gens font ça
pour perdre du poids mais beaucoup de
médecins disent que c'est une bonne
chose pour prévenir certaines maladies
ne pas manger pendant une longue période
de temps
les données montrent que si l'intervalle
et de 16 12 heures il n'y a pas de
réelle différence
il faut que les repas soit à la même
heure chaque jour et ne rien manger
entre les repas
je veux dire tous sont les données les
plus simples c'est comme ça que nous
sommes supposés vivre un espace on
chassait dans la nature ont mangé notre
droit pour le dîner on avait des restes
pour le matin les cuisines équipées
n'existait pas jusqu'à une centaine
d'années l'idée selon laquelle la
nourriture doit être abondante est une
invention plutôt moderne
quand nous mangeons en permanence aux
hormones de stress reste au même niveau
donc entre une situation vous mangé la
même quantité de calories trois repas
par jour et une vous manger à votre
guise vous avez 81 % de chances de plus
d'avoir du diabète dans la deuxième
situation même si c'est la même quantité
de calories donc les gens ont
aujourd'hui tendance à être obsédé par
la santé d'un extrême à l'autre nous ne
prêtons pas attention du tout à la façon
dont nous mangeons quand nous mangeons
ce que nous faisons avec notre corps
comme fumer et boire beaucoup d'alcool
où nous sommes parfaitement obsédé et
pour être tout à fait honnête je ne sais
pas ce qu est la meilleure option parce
que quand on est obsédé à ce point j'ai
l'impression qu'un tel stress du cerveau
peut causer d'autres maladies qu'en
pensez vous je suis d'accord avec vous
je pense qu'il faut trouver un équilibre
que vous devez faire attention à vous
vous devez réunir des données vous
concernant mais pas de manière excessive
vous savez allez voir votre médecin une
fois par an et le faire vérifier votre
tension artérielle n'a aucun sens il
vaut mieux la vérifier plusieurs fois ou
encore la journée lorsque vous avez dit
de relaxer lorsque vous êtes triste
après un appel téléphonique etc et
apporter ces données à votre médecin il
faut faire attention à ce qu'on mange
il faut regarder son corps et regarder
les changements il faut connaître ses
données mais pas de manière excessive ça
n'est d'aucune aide
la modération est la clef de presque
tous en santé il a été prouvé que tous
les extrêmes ne marchait pas croyez-vous
les maladies psychosomatiques
car 50% des très bons médecins à qui
j'ai parlé disent non c'est vraiment
n'importe quoi ça n'existe pas d'autres
disent vous pouvez réellement guérir les
maladies si votre état d'esprit est
simple si vous permet de surmonter une
maladie vous serez en bonne santé et
resteront en vie qu'en pensez vous ce
n'est pas ce que j'en pense ce que
disent les données données montrent que
la dernière hypothèse est la bonne
l'optimisme dans un système de croyances
induit 30% de plus de meilleurs
résultats dans tous les domaines
à chaque essai clinique et données sont
là si vous êtes optimiste et que vous
avez un système de croyances vous allez
me dire mais parce que je crois ce sont
les données et pouvez vous l'expliquer
en tant que médecin de manière
scientifique comment ce que vous pensez
vraiment changé les molécules les
cellules dans votre corps votre corps
discute avec lui même en permanence il
peut se sentir bien et avoir la nausée
en l'espace d'une seconde autres tractus
gastro intestinal et votre cerveau se
parlent
nous ne pouvons pas expliquer cette
connexion ne pouvons pas la modéliser je
ne sais pas comment fonctionne votre
cerveau j'en ai aucune idée
est ce que je sais c'est qu'un système
de croyances marche je le vois quand on
est optimisme on va mieux points et nous
devons donc nous soutenir mutuellement
pour les parvenir de réussir au mieux
en tant que société et en tant
qu'ensemble mais non je ne peux pas
l'expliquer si seulement je pouvais d'un
système émergents complexe je peux
comprendre cette fonction du cerveau
davies merci beaucoup pour ses
explications
merci pour votre travail et bonne chance
dans tous vos projets futurs
amusez vous bien à moscou merci c'est un
privilège d'être ici je suis très
heureux d'être à moscou c'était un
plaisir
[Musique]